では よろしくお願いします
今日のテーマはまあこういうテーマになります
かっこよさという テーマで
一応皆様があのパティパダーで読まれている文章は
まあこういう文章になると思います
まあかっこいいっていうことは
まあ一応よく言われていることで
まあ我々はとにかくそうなりたいと誰でも思ってます
そういうことで まあ一般的な考え方はこのような考え方だと思います
まあ読めない漢字もありますから
飛ばします  そういうことで
まあ結構頭も良くて ユーモアもあって
よく気配りをできる まあ優しさを身につけているということをね
俗世間の一般の感覚ならば
こんなイメージに落ち着きそうですねということで
しかし これがかっこいい人でしょうかっていうね
我々は皆簡単にそのようになれるのでしょうか？と
だから 今まで言ったような感じで
まあ頭も良くて 仕事もできて
まあ優しくて活発に動けるとかね
スタイルも良くてとかね
まあそんなものになれるんでしょうかというと
そう簡単にはなれないということもありますね
で ということで まあ我々考えているかっこよさっていうのは
なんとなくもう神話物語になっているんですね
残念なことに 実際の人生はこの神話のごとくうまくいかないんです
これは決して認めたくないんですね
どこかで神話のようにうまくいくだろうと期待するんですよ
でまあ昨日いろいろ経典を調べるときは
なんかすごく厳しい経典が一つ見つかりまして
今日は引用しませんけど
あまりにも厳しくて お釈迦様はとことん人を怒鳴っているところで
金持ちになりたければね
祈るんじゃないんだよと
祈って金持ちになるならば
どんなバカでも金持ちになりますよと
金が欲しければ汗を垂らして朝早く起きて
夜遅くまで仕事をしなさいよと
で 頭いい人間になりたければ
祈るんじゃないんだよと
祈ってそうなるならば
もう誰でも頭がいいんだよと
まあ頭が良き良き良くなりたければ
もう智慧のある人々に出会って
話し合って 相談ディスカッションして対応して
物事を理解しなくちゃいけないんだよというふうなリストがあったんです
しかし そういう話は嫌いんですよ
まあ奇跡で まあ神様の恵みでまあ降ってくれるならば
もうありがたく もうもうまあパクりついたいというかね
これがもう凡家人なんですね
仏教はそれにはすごく嫌がるんです
神様の恵みが降ってきて
まあ何でもうまくいくんだぞと
一度もそういう試しは世の中でないんです
誰でも何かに達したならば
並々の努力の結果なんですよ
だから まあ愚か者は置いておいて
智慧のある人々に必要なのはどう頑張ればいいかとかね
どのようにすれば良くなるのかというこの方法なんですね
その具体的な教えなんですよ
それを釈迦様は教えていて
かなり嫌われているんですね
そこで言論もありますけど
業の話も運命だ運命だというために言っているわけじゃないんです
頑張っても物事はうまくいったりいかなかったりする
ですから落ち着きなさいよという話なんです
言論の話になったってね
例えば商売したんだからといって確実に繁盛するということはありません
あらゆる社会条件によってうまくいくかいかないかということなんですね
たまたま全部揃ったってもうまくいかない時もあります
ついてない時もあります
その時でも まあ業ではないかと思って落ち着いて次のことに挑戦するんです
だから この具体的な教えはものすごく嫌われるという現象があります
世の中で 宗教っていうのは何でも奇跡でやってくれる世界だとと思っていて
そういう人を騙す世界はとんでもないんだと
お釈迦様がものすごく厳しく批判しているんですよ
お祈りすれば天国に行くとか
もう何か念仏を唱えたらそれだけで天国とか
そんな甘い話じゃないんだと
宇宙の法則は 宇宙の法則というのはそれほど難しくはないんですよね
我々の身の回りのことを見れば
そちらにあるのは宇宙の法則なんですよ
何かどこかに このもうもう皿の上でもいいんですけど
種入れてお祈りしてください
どうか芽が出ますようにとかね
どうか花が咲きますようにとか
咲いたならば私は仏教をやめます
もし種を植えて花が咲いて欲しければ
それはちゃんと植木鉢に植えて
水をあげて 暖かいところに入れてあげて
日に当たって太陽に当たって見せてあげなくちゃいかんでしょうに
だから 適切な努力によって適切な良い結果が得られる
そこで その努力の過程でいろいろ自分がごちゃごちゃやったりすると
頭がおかしくなって 感情的になって
いろんなことをやっちゃうと
うまくいかない そういうことで
因果法則ということは宇宙の法則であって
私の命の法則でもあって
周りでどこを見てもあるのは因果法則なんですね
それを理解しておけば
何のこともないんだよと
そこをそれだけで 商売繁盛に仏教は語っているわけじゃないんです
長生きするために仏教を語っているわけでもないんです
なおさらもう先に先へ語るんですよ
例えば 法則をわかったとしても
法則にはめられてそれでいいのかといったっても
それにも意味だよと ただ生まれて年取ってくたびれて死ぬだけのサイクルでしょうにと
そこは繰り返して繰り返して起こるんだよと
どこまでそんなくだらない繰り返しやるのかと
ですから 因果法則を乗り越える道もありますよということで
人間には最終的な答えまで目的まで教えています
そういうことだから 今日にしたっても
そういう具体的な話にはなります
大体人間 誰一人も神様にも王子様にもなりません
ならないんだけど 我々は今人間に生まれたことは一回限りと思った方がいいんです
それでこの短い人生の中で失敗すると
もう話にならないんですよ
人間に生まれたならば
誰一人も失敗して欲しくないんです
そんな大変なことじゃないんです
しっかり生きるということはとても簡単単純なんです
なのに人間というのはむちゃくちゃ失敗する
ほとんど失敗する人はいくらでもいるんであって
成功する人っていうのはすごく少ないんですね
それはどういうことかというと
全然具体的でない 合理的じゃない
理性の一欠片もない 神様は信仰しているんです
占い信仰しているんです
それではね 私もこの電車で来た時は
星座占いは長であったんですけど
もうあまり早くも消えちゃいますからね
もう読めないんですね
英語だったら早く読めますけど
日本がちょっと遅いんです
私は占い読みますよ なぜかというと
いかに当たってないかということを調べるのがすごく楽しみなんです
いかにいい加減な もうどうでもいいことを言っているんではないかと
今日は考える行動だよとかね
何言ってるんですか これ
今日だけじゃなくて 毎日そういうことでしょうね
自信過剰は危険ですよと
今日だけ 食べ過ぎに注意しましょうとか
今日だけの占いで そんな占いでしょうに
ということは どんなバカにも占い師になれるということなんです
だって聞いてる人はもっとアホだから
もう大丈夫で商売繁盛します
そういうわけで このもう占いを信仰したり
とにかくヘリクツで非合理的で
迷信に凝り固まって生きようとするんです
すべて自分の腕次第だとわかれば
もっとこの世の中は良い世の中になるんですよ
人生短いと思っておけば
ゲームみたいに何回も繰り返しできるわけじゃないんだと
あのゲームセンターのゲームに比較したらいいんですよ
100円ぐらいでしょうか
わかりませんだけどね
100円入れたらもう 1 日中遊べるわけじゃないんです
時間リミットがあるんです
しかし 腕次第 腕が良ければかなり長い時間は遊べます
しかし ゲームをプログラム作る人は腕のいい子が来て
これ 8時間も続けてやっちゃうと商売になりません
だからどう頑張っても 30 分以内でもうものすごい腕のいい人が頑張っても 30
分以内でカチンと切れるように作っているんですよ
だから人生も同じことで
寿命は決まっていて 死ぬことははっきりしてあって
1 日はもうもう取り戻せませんよ
そういうわけで 我々はなんでそこは嫌がるんですかね
今日 1 日しかないんだよという教えをね
今日失敗 失敗するんじゃないんだよと
今日泣くんじゃないんだよと
今日喧嘩するんじゃないんだよと
今日に限って嫌な気分でいるんじゃないんだよと
まあ私は周りがそうさせる場合はとにかく逃げる
おい 周りのおかげで嫌な気分になってなりたくはないんだよと
すぐ逃げる 逃げて 自分がすごい自分なりの明るい環境を作って入るんです
まあ一応この 自分なりに充実感を感じて生きていきたいということは人間の希望なんですね
それは悪い希望じゃないんです
後悔することになる人生は避けたい
生きる目的をはっきりしたい
自分が何をやっているのかと
よく私に聞くんですよ
私はどうすればいいかと
勝手にいいんじゃないでしょうかと答えていますけどね
何をしたって私に関係ないんだよと
まあ関係あるんだったら出ていってくださいと
いうぐらいなんですけど
やっぱり一人一人がどうすればよろしいか
どんな生き方が自分に適しているのかということは知りたいでしょうに
それ他人に聞くっていうことは
本当に まあしょうがないって言えばしょうがないんだけど
まあ子供は聞くのはね
まあどうってことはないんですけど
これ大人が聞くんだからね
そういうことで 自分の持って生まれた能力がありまして
それが本当にギリギリまで育てているのかという問題なんですよ
神に委ねると生まれたまんまで
もう肉の塊だけで死んじゃいますよ
肉の塊で死んじゃうと
もう地獄以外ないんで
処理するところは天界にも上がりません
ですからこの我々は生まれる時はもう人間で
死ぬまで幸福に生きていられるために必要な種を持って生まれてくるんです
それはまた自然法則 決して不思議なことでも
神に恵みで与えられたものでもないんです
当たり前の因果法則なんですよ
壁建物の外の壁でちょこっとした葉っぱ 1 枚が出ていたならば
その壁の周りにその植物に必要な栄養があるという話なんです
全く栄養が何もなかったら
もう出てきませんよ どこかの壁に緑色のコケというんですか
出ているならば そちらにはすごくそのコケにとってはいい環境なんです
だから育ているんです
だから因果法則っていうのはそういうことで
ごく当たり理解しにくいんだけど
ごく当たり前の毎日目の目に見える映るものなんです
ですから どんなところでも
この地球で人間が生まれたならば
それは生まれた人間に死ぬまで幸福に
人生を満たすための能力は種としてあるんです
そこからなんですよ 問題は
壁に苔が生えたっても
夏になってきて スーッと一日強烈な日が当たっている場合は
あまりにも暑すぎてもう死ぬかもしれません
もしこの兵の持ち主が苔の方が可愛いと思うならば
そこで何とかしなくちゃいけないんですね
あまり日が当たらないようにとか
そこで我々は適切に自分の能力に水をあげているのかと
適切に剪定して育てているのかという
これは自分の責任なんです
それが教えてあげることの大人の責任なんです
そこで生命の大人も 親としてお釈迦様でしたから
智慧の完成者がお釈迦様ですから
何のルール規則書くこともなく
何の秘密もなく 生きる方法は全部公に教えているんです
それだけじゃなくて この教えをわけもわからない
もう詩とか歌とかね 特にヴェーダ語のチャンバスというね
ものすごいややこしいなぞなぞの言語があるんですよ
そういうものに訳すると覚えやすいんです
そういう風にするなよと
自分自分の表現で学びなさいよと
教えだけは決して隠すなよと
人が聞いたら教えてあげなさいよと
法だけは消すなよ ケチるなよと
それくらい人間のことを心配して教えてるんです
この中でこの間違ってる教えは隠した方がいいんだよと
人間の知識にぶつかると変だとわかりますからね
人間は研究したり調べたりする場合はね
間違った教えはすぐバレます
理屈成り立ってないとすぐもうバレます
そういう不完全に人間に幸福を教えない
人間を奴隷にしたがってる教えなら
まあ隠してありがたがってもいいんだよと
しかし 人間の幸福のために教えてるブッダの言葉は決して隠すなよと
密教っていうのはもうとんでもない単語なんです
仏教は密教にならないと
はっきりとパーリ経典にはあります
これ大乗仏教はかなり胸を張って言いますけど
いろんなこと 我々はあれだこれだとか
ほとんどパーリ経典でなんかわかりませんけど
将来のことを見ていたみたいですね
これではありません これではありません
これではありませんと
ちゃんと書いてます しょ
ぐらいの人々は自分が出家だと言い張ったりして
青い服を着たり赤い服を着たりするんだよと
アパダンになりますよ
髪の毛までちゃんと整理整頓して
あの 何て言いますか あれはまあ
なりやす ちゃんともうそういうふうな人々も現れますよと
これはブッダの道じゃありませんと
そこまでやるんだから何か怪しいんですよ
とにかくパーリ教典も
だから滅挙にならんとならん
滅挙の人はいけませんと
人間にわからない言語の人はいけませんと
だから私はものすごいこの小学生の子供たちの日本語で
あの そんな立派な日本語っていうのは
勉強していれば 私にとっては何のこともない簡単だと思いますよ
しかし あえて勉強しないので
難しい単語とか なぜかと勉強しちゃうと
外国語だからすぐすぐ行ってしまっちゃいます
そうすると聞く人々はありがたい話でしたと
で 帰ります 小学生レベルで喋るんだと言ったら
いやまあ聞く価値もないんだと言って
口だけ開けて待ってますという
まあどちらにしたっても結果がないんですけど
まあそれでも自分が自分の仕事はする
まあだから人に生き方
どのように生きていれば立派でしょうかと
それははっきり教えています
そこであの誤解ですよ
このお釈迦様がこの豊かになることを否定しているんだとか
それはないんです 人間がまあそれぞれ勝手な希望いろいろあるんです
例えばここ王様がまあ独裁者ですけど
もう国を平和で治めたいんでしょうに
暴動 乱暴 暴動などは嫌でしょう
それでお釈迦様に聞くんです
どうすれば国民が暴動を起こさないで
私の独裁 独裁政治をね
認めてくれるでしょうかと
独裁はダメだ お前出て行けという話はないんだよ
お釈迦様は それなら王様
こういうふうにしなさいよと
人の希望を叶うように教えるんです
それがすべてだと思うなよと
国を治めたってもね あと人って死にますからね
先も考えておきなさいよ
だから国を治める人は
一時的な平和で国民を抑えることではなくて
長期的に考えて 自分の死後のことも心配して政治をやるんだよと言うと
失踪された王様にとってはものすごい失踪よりも何倍も大事な道をもう教えられたことになるんです
それから幸福になりたいと
かっこいい人間になりたいと思っても
方法が教えてあげたっても
その方法が実行できなかったら意味がないでしょう
そういうわけで 我々に幸福になる道を教えてほしいんですが
その上 その方法が簡単に実行できる方法でなければまた意味がないんです
方法はあるんだけど 実行できませんよというと意味がない
方法じゃないんです だからそういうプラグマティカルというね
まあ立場から仏教は語っています
はい これで前書きのところ終わりまして
もう話に入ります  はい